shooter's studio people can fly
announced its new game out writers at e3
last year
it's a third-person shooter that gives
you a host of cool superpowers set in a
dense and fairly dark sci-fi world we
played the first few hours of outriders
at a recent preview event in Los Angeles
and learned a heck of a lot about it
here's everything we know about
outriders so far our writers is an RPG
infused cover shooter that feels like
it's borrowing from two other people can
fly games Gears of War judgment and
bullets tour you carry three weapons
which includes two switchable primary
guns and a pair of sidearms you can use
when ammo is low the guns we saw
included assault rifles shotguns and
snipers and it seems those weapons will
carry different perks and capabilities
in my few hours with the game though
shotguns felt the best as they blow off
enemy limbs and heads in a way that
carries all the satisfaction of similar
guns in Gears of War
you can also expect to modify your
weapons and armor over time to change
how they work and their effects you'll
do a lot of shooting in outriders but
the game is main appeal is the special
powers you'll get as one of the altered
after the game's prologue when your
powers unlock you'll choose from one of
three classes the Devastator a tank like
character who can affect gravity for
seismic attacks the Pyromancer a more
mid-range fighter who can take out
multiple enemies with flame based
attacks and the trickster who bends time
and space to teleport behind enemies
slow them down and take them apart with
hit-and-run tactics it's possible to
customize your three classes throughout
the course of the game as you level up
your character thanks to an extensive
skill tree as you play you'll unlock
eight different abilities for your class
allowing you to switch between them as
you play I saw 3 during the course of
the demo and each cools down pretty
quickly so while the base of outriders
is a cover shooter your abilities allow
you to run and gun quite a bit you're
not gonna spend the whole game stuck
behind chest-high walls the thing about
the classes in outriders is that each
has a special healing mechanic which
encourages you to play to their
strengths I played as the trickster who
is healed by taking out enemies at close
range my abilities included teleporting
and with a shotgun in hand it meant I
was able to pop across the battlefield
and devastate someone while they were
still in cover heal myself up and then
take their position to flank out the
remaining enemies you can play outriders
alone but the game supports drop-in
dropout co-op for up to 3 players there
are also no limitations on classes you
can run a group of 3 tricksters if you
want or each pick a separate class and
support each other with your different
abilities you choose your class early at
the end of outriders prologue and once
you make that choice you're locked in
for the duration of the game outriders
is mostly a shooter but it also mixes in
a lot of RPG elements in the vein of
something like Mass Effect as you play
you'll constantly be coming across armor
and weapons for different stat boosts
the loot you'll find will vary in rarity
like in a lot of RPG type games these
days with better guns and armor being
tougher to come by as you level up your
character you'll also level up the
game's a world level which is
effectively a difficulty level you earn
and can set as you choose the higher
your world level the tougher the enemies
you'll encounter but the better the loot
you'll earn
the way you have to gain experience to
unlock new harder world levels but if
you're ever facing a challenge you can't
handle it you can always turn it back
down to a point you've already unlocked
my time without writers included a
prologue that set up the story and gave
a deep look at the lore of the world you
play one of the titular outriders a
character you create at the start of the
game and a member of a colony group
that's trying to spread humanity to a
new world called Enoch things were bad
back on earth with society collapsing as
resources became scarce during the
conflicts that sprung up because of
those problems outriders were a heroic
group of scientists and military types
who fought to help humanity survive on
the colony ship your job is to go down
to Enoch in the first wave of colonists
in order to secure it for everybody else
the trip to Enoch has taken 80 years and
from all accounts the rest of humanity
might have wiped itself out in that
period after landing the outriders
encounter a strange energy storm that
comes to be called the anomaly it's
completely unpredictable sometimes
annihilating anything in its path and
sometimes giving animals and humans
ridiculous powers in the prologue most
of the remaining out writers are killed
by the anomaly which also renders most
of the colonists advanced human
technology worthless after you are
zapped by the anomaly your surviving
friends throw you back into cryostasis
to save your life when you wake up again
Enoch isn't the mostly idyllic place he
left but instead has been transformed
into a war-torn hellscape turns out you
slept for 30 years and in that time the
remaining colonists were dropped onto
Enoch
only to find the anomaly killing people
and knocking out the technology
essential to survival factions have been
fighting over food and scraps ever since
with some people becoming altered making
them more or less godlike but often
corrupted by their power story seems to
be a pretty big focus for outriders with
a lot of time in the prologue spent on
dialogue between characters
okay I had that under control although
you shouldn't expect branching
storylines or conversation choices
however you will find optional side
missions to complete that will add more
depth to the main campaign which sounds
like it should clock in at about 25
hours we know one last thing about
outriders its release window expected in
holiday 2020 for ps4 Xbox one and PC as
well as PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X
so that's everything we know so far
about outriders are you excited to check
out Enoch and people can flies latest
are you looking to play the trickster
Pyromancer or Devastator leave us your
thoughts in the comments below